okay hi everyone welcome to another
wolfram language design review part of
our incremental language design
uh language development series we have a
variety of topics here
starting off with things about trees
okay so
i see wait a minute there's a couple of
different issues here
so the thing that's driving me crazy
about trees
is that i'm trying to use them
as
representation
without named
entries if you understand what i'm
saying that's the next item on the
agenda after this
okay
could i just to scratch that itch could
we just look at that first because it
was driving me just absolutely crazy and
then i'll be paying more attention to
what you've got up here i think it's
also relevant actually to this
um
unless unless there's a huge reason not
to do that i mean that we can't
literally in jeremy hear from design but
i'm sure they'll have some input on this
as well i think they will yes i think
they will
um okay so the issue is
how do i get this i don't want the
frigging small circles there or if i do
i want to show them in a different way
or i want to align them to just a single
thing
and
okay so let's just run this
and um okay so current method of doing
it is something absolutely horrifically
horrendous
i mean to me
right currently tree element label and
trey element style take a position
right well they could take a symbolic
thing i mean they
okay look the way this works for graphs
is
you know worst case you're saying vertex
style arrow and then you've got you've
got a list of elements
okay so wait a minute so what do you say
something that corresponds to a vertex
and a graph is a position for trees and
that's what we followed
okay so here
i don't even know what that is
tree position of tree blank zero minus
two what the heck is that that's the
position of every inner node
why is that an inner node because it
isn't minus one
yes an inner node is zero from zero yeah
it's from zero to minus one so it's not
the leaf
nodes that's pretty horrifying
okay so let's just so this
is that now i want to restyle the a's as
well
okay let me tell you an example of
something i want to do yeah everything
we're discussing for labels should also
apply for style i agree
right but what i'm saying is here's what
i want to do i've got big trees
okay
and i won't want any of this kind of
detailed stuff i just want to color the
a's blue
and the b is red for example
and i want those to be nodes
um somebody's making a bunch of
background noise could you please put
yourself on mute of course
um
okay so
did you get what i'm saying so how would
i do that here
do you understand what i'm saying
yes and we have a few options okay fine
let's look at them
okay but i mean that objective is i want
to be able to get rid of i want to be
able to style everything here
i mean edge style and vertex style
should presumably work
tree versions of them
but yes
we're not literally using vertex style
from graph we're using tree element
style tree element label
yeah i know but i wonder whether we
should allow one
to use vertex style as well
as a low-level version
do you see what i'm saying as a just to
say i don't want any of this tree
element i just want to you'd have to
somehow implicitly
have these you'd have to have implicit
vertex names which we do have when we
convert these two graphs right
sure if i convert this to a graph
if i say tree graph of this
so you're proposing that if you
specified a vertex style then that would
apply to the
that would be as if you said tree
element style
uh not sure that i'm right about this
i'm not sure i'm right by the way
there's a bunch of weird background
noise here i don't know what just my
heater kicking on
um
seems unconvincing anyway okay
uh
look i i want to say this tree
functionality is so close to being super
useful it just isn't quite there yet so
let me give you an example of a place
where
uh
in um
um let me see
uh
where is it i need to find the um
combinator
have you seen these the the wfr
functions for
um combinator rendering
yes
okay so that's an example wherever it is
i mean those things so where are they
like
is this relevant i don't even know what
this is that's this okay that's not
relevant
although it's sort of interesting
this way of presenting something which
is after all a tree is sort of
interesting
this is you know and it relates to the
things we had earlier on in this agenda
which we haven't yet yet
and it's straightforward to make a plot
like that
with our current functionality
okay okay so where is the um
where is the thing where is the um
combinator expression graph is that the
thing
yeah it's these kinds of things
for much bigger
right right so the first thing i want to
point out here is that these combinators
you're not using the default expression
tree you're using atoms
which is a structure that just doesn't
put anything in the inner nodes to begin
with and then it's not an issue of
specifying labels okay well so so you're
telling me that if i do this
and i just take this out of this
um
so if i say a
tree
uh expression tree
of this comma atoms
yes
ah
okay but now i want to make the um
the okay now help me to do the actual
thing i want
okay so i want so first of all i want a
different aspect ratio i just i just
want to see whether it works
okay so aspect ratio one okay dandy i'm
happy
okay now i want to color these things
okay
so i want to color
let's say i want to color the s's blue
and the k's
i don't know red and blue or something
how do i do that
so you need to do tree position
nope you lost you lost the game you lost
the game there i mean i don't think
that's the right thing to do well so
that's the thing and then we have the
three proposals below okay fine so so
right now what i will be doing
okay so here
the reason that's nothing is what is
that actual tree element if i do an
input form of this
it's null
okay so if i replace it with null
then that's the that's there's that's
the thing that is rendered like this
so up here
if i were to simply replace
if i were to say expression tree
of this
slash dot
small circle
arrow null
i guess that's because tree is atomic
hacklaurius doesn't work
can you do the replacement inside i'm
going to i'm going to that's the
hakka maximus or something
um
wow
so this is what what we were suggesting
about doing a trimap of null function
which is by far the simplest
method currently
um
where am i saving this
should i save it under trees or is that
going to confuse other things
let's save this under trees yeah no we
really should have this
um
we really should break the well we know
we're gonna save these things we should
probably break these agendas into
multiple pieces
so that we can save them in the right
places
um
okay in any case back to this
so okay so you've got a proposal here
for what to do
so can you evaluate the three map before
the currency map so do you see that
the previous line so that line is quite
simple
well
in some generalized sense of simplicity
i agree that that line isn't terrible
but that line is basically doing the
same hacky thing
of replacing
it's replacing in the tree not in the
expression
i know that but what i really want to do
is i want to replace i mean you know
what i want to do here
is to say
like in this
thing here
i want to replace
you know and this is just bonkers to
have to do it this way
s with red
k with blue
no you you what you really want is to
be able to directly specify this entry
element style somehow
probably yeah okay all right let's take
a look here so you're saying
um
okay tree element label
tree level based
don't we have a tree leaves function
yes we do don't we so we've already
crossed the bridge of using the leaves
word
so i mean in a sense the most obvious
you know leaves and non okay so what
what what are the criteria by which i
want to do things with things
i want to say
you know i want to say leaves versus
non-leaves
that's that's going to be one criterion
the other thing is
content based
uh
leaves us and non-leaves or possibly
level but i think it's mostly going to
be leaves
um leaves versus non-leaves and the
other one is content-based styling
right those are the two cases in my view
do you agree
yep
okay so let's try and address those two
things
oh
no
no
you've asked for tree element label
function
we want that but not doing i mean this
is just acting
i don't think that's the right way to do
it
what the hell is this
no
that is just suggesting that we add
atomic arguments as a structure and it
just gives you that tree
and that's just an implementation of it
okay what's the right name for this
because atomic arguments is something i
would never understand
well we have what does we have arguments
and we have atoms which is the atoms of
the full tree
and we want okay
what is the arguments
that's arguments
why is that the right name for arguments
i mean why is that why is arguments the
right name for this
the data of the nodes are the arguments
of expressions
i see
so every node is an argument
except the root node which is just the
whole expression
why isn't this called sub-expressions
sub-expression do sub expressions
it's everything
i see so subexpressions
really drills down and shows me all the
subparts
okay but so now
what you're saying is you want arguments
okay so atoms
so atoms is to sub-expressions
as atomic arguments would be to
arguments
atoms is just sub-expressions where you
only care about the atoms everything
else is null right
um
basically the difference is
that there are no heads and in the
arguments case there are no heads right
right
you don't uh that's the only difference
between you don't represent
yes you don't include the heads as
subtrees
do we have a heads option an expression
tree
yes
so does it switch between those two
heads is like tree form
no wait a minute wait a minute i mean i
mean a heads arrow true or false no
that's just this we should
that's just the structure that you're
specifying
no i understand that but maybe this will
be a clearer way to do it because i've
i've seen this a bunch of times and i've
never understood do we have good
examples on the page
yes
i think this is a place where we should
use oh there we go
okay and this is going to get extended
with like xml and like i just don't
think heads is appropriate for this
no but i'm saying
that's a way that you could go from
arguments
and you could decide that arguments with
heads arguments as heads false
sub-expressions as is arguments with
heads true
so what ian is saying is that we have
plans for many different second
arguments for which heads true will not
make much sense oh i understand that
all right but maybe what we want
like i i think this is very confusing i
mean i'm sure i invented these terms but
i don't i don't really believe in them
at this point
i don't think these are the right names
because i'm i'm having a really hard
time understanding
okay so heads means what how do you
yeah so that's my question is how do you
distinguish between heads and arguments
well what does heads do i don't even
understand what heads why is there a g
there this says f of a b where did the g
come from
the root of the
tree is the head of the expression
that is what tree form does
and that is the it's pretty much the
default expression tree the default
expression tree is head
trees so tree form handles this one way
level specs handle it another way
okay let me let me zoom out for a second
here so
there are a couple of different issues
there's
what
wait a minute
okay so the one issue is
is a node a trivial node
or a named node so to speak
am i making sense
another issue is
okay so atoms and sub-expressions
have the same
nodes
but they're named differently
right
heads and arguments
have the same shape
but just have different payloads
just like
okay how would you characterize the
difference in shapes
that's basically whether they include
the head throw is heads is somehow i
think heads
goes to false
and the bottom row is heads goes to true
but
okay so let's talk about xml for a
second heads goes to true could also be
arguably the difference between head
trees and heads
so i just think it's not very clear what
the head's optional i i understand that
what we have right now is un is
completely unclear
so you know anything we got to think
about so
usually heads to true
means
go into the head take account of the
head
as opposed to ignore the head
right and that's sort of the difference
between these two rows the first one
takes the cut pays attention to the head
it examines the head so to speak and
this one does not examine the head
backwards
i have a backwards you're correct
right so this one examines the head and
that one does not
and by examine it means there is a sub
tree that corresponds to the head
exactly
right in the other one there is no
subtree corresponding to the head
okay so let's just imagine that we did
that but we said
that we the heads goes to true or false
determines whether it goes in whether it
makes a subtree for the head which is
the analog
of saying you know of map
you know
g onto f of a b
if i'm not mistaken heads goes to true
there
would do this right
it's the same type of thing
make sense
so
uh
now
i'm really believing in this because i
cannot remember any of these okay so if
if you did sub expressions and you said
heads goes to false you would get what
we're calling arguments
right
i understand that conversion
yeah i have no idea what heads is
supposed to do in the other three cases
okay well let's look at it let's look at
it i mean what we've got
is
we've also got the question of whether
because i so so i would just say a
metapoint the the functions that take
the option heads goes to true are
precisely the functions that treat
expressions the way that sub-expressions
and arguments do
this is why this is i understand that i
understand i understand it's trees
differently in different functions
i'm sorry
you're saying that okay look the
difference between these different
things is what the payloads are right so
first question is
question one
what nodes exist
question two
what is the payload of each node yes
okay so i'm claiming question one
is completely determined right now by
heads goes to true or false
yes so now let's talk about payloads
okay
um
okay so let's understand what the
possibilities are the payloads could be
okay first question is are the
intermediate payloads
blanked out effectively is it leaves
only okay so so one payload is
only the leaves
are filled in
and that's useful in all of these cases
i mean we only provide that for atoms
but what we're asking for right so
that's atoms and that's what we're what
i have is atomic arguments here
right like fine the goal
so so one thing is only the leaves are
filled in okay that's case one
case two
just coming out this is the case that
solves your problem
no i realized that i realized that so
the next case is that
um it's accumulative that there are
really three cases here it's
uh
you know
the node
is
quotes what's new at that node
i believe
another is the node is
everything below that node is that right
and it could be everything below that
node i mean i don't understand why there
isn't a version
with heads goes to true
that isn't head trees
that's sub-expressions
no because it's got this actual tree
here
see sub-expressions could have a
sub-tree as the name as the payload of
that element there
it doesn't i see well so the reason that
head trees is the way it is is because
it and atoms both have minimal
redundancy
great but what i'm saying is
i'm just saying yeah
you could have a version of
sub-expressions that also has trees
exactly so we've got orthogonal issues
here we've got only the leaves are
filled in we've got
the node is everything below that node
which is this case or this case
no no which cases is the node this is
only the node that is filled in right
the
this expression and everything below it
is arguments and sub-expressions
those two cases
okay and the next question is
is the node
given
as an expression or a subtree expression
you know is the node payload
an ordinary expression or another
or tree
or itself a tree
okay so so okay so what we need here in
my opinion is several options so i think
what's new at that node is the head
what's that what do you have in quotes
what's new at that node i think we just
mean the head
is that what we mean because not for the
leaf nodes
okay yeah
for inner nodes it's the head
okay ie
for internodes
the head
so the cases are
we only care about the leaves
or
the inner nodes could be the head or the
entire expression
okay hold on let me write that down
again let me write that down again okay
case one
only leaves only the leaves
and if it's the leaves
they too
okay so another issue is
okay here's another issue i've run into
i don't want to go all the way down i
want an excluded expressions thing for
expression tree like for example i have
x blanks and i want those to be treated
as atoms
okay so this is like excluded patterns
or something excluded what are we
calling that excluded um what are we
calling that
it's used in simplifying many other
things excluded something or other what
is it
uh is that what i want
what do i want here
i've got the wrong name
um
okay another thing we want is
uh exclude this is actually an important
thing we want to
interpreting sub-expressions as specific
oh okay there okay so we want to say
what
should be treated as atomic
eg
you know x blank etc you get what i'm
saying yep
i also think we probably should allow
verbatim or something
to specify that something is atomic
so that you can spray that into the tree
to specify that it should be atomic
did you get what i'm saying
i get the idea um
verbatim gives me pause but i'm not sure
that's the right thing either about that
okay so case one
let's go through this again please okay
one only the leaves
are labeled
only the leaves
have a non-null payload yes
there's no question of labeling because
it's actually what the i mean is is it
is it ever a question of labeling
what is it it's just a matter of payload
okay
don't we also want the possibility of
expression tree having the full payload
but having the labeling set so you don't
see the payload absolutely like tree
form does that
like tree form
shows you okay wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait so then there's another sub
case which is
is
um is the payload
manipulation
actually done to payloads
or only to their formatting
right you see what i'm saying
well they have to determine the payload
we're constructing a tree we have to
decide what the payload is no and it's
kind of anywhere the other and then we
could have a payload it could be aspects
that involve the formatting like
tooltips yes i understand that but i
mean right what i'm saying is we know we
want this
right okay yeah only to the formatting
ieee
there is no just nothing displayed
there is only a tool tip etc yep
i i do want to say i don't want to make
a meta comment here i mean i've been
using trees okay
and we are so close to having something
super
convenient and useful but we just have a
few rough edges
so let's get those nailed
you know
squashed out
um okay so only the leaves can have a
non null have a non-null payload
okay case two what's case two
case two is when you do want labeled uh
internodes
and then it becomes a question of
a whip then it's what nodes exist and
what is the payload like your two
questions above well okay
okay but wait a second wait a second we
know what nodes exist we've determined
that above here okay okay so now we're
only talking about payload so the
payloads only the leaves doesn't have a
non-null case two would be we want the
heads of the expressions
okay so intermediate nodes
are shown by are shown as heads
and the case three
is intermediate expressions
are shown as sub expressions right the
intermediate nodes are the full sub
expressions yeah
intermediate nodes are full
sub-expressions
okay and there's a fourth case
the fourth case is
intermediate nodes
convert the sub expressions to trees
intermediate nodes are sub-expressions
as trees
okay
all right
good now
we might also want the leaves
to have a null payload and the inner
nodes to have non-null payloads
all we might want
in general
or another sub case here
is
you know sub case
we want inner nodes
labeled by
a
pattern or something
by a function relative to their content
you see what i'm saying
and i think that's what comes to their
head specifically what's that as opposed
to their head exactly exactly we're
taking either the full so that's the
intermediate between case two and case
three
is we apply a function to determine what
to show
okay so so then
look to me
i mean i'm just gonna make it up for
right now okay let's say
tree leaves display function or
something
and tree
what are we calling it non-leaves
display function
and that would determine
so tree leaves i'm i'm making this up
for right now but i mean that this is
now
this would say
i want um
uh if the tree leaves display function
is none let's say
then don't display the leaves
or if it's you know with some function
funk it will do something to leaves like
it might turn
s to blue and and you know whatever it
is you know what i'm saying
well so i think
there there should be separate style
function labels i agree i agree
and shape function
yes
there's just no vertex there
yeah i agree with that so i think we're
going to need a bunch of options here
and i think i'm you know i'm sorry but
it's i think there's a better way to do
it i think it's unusable right now so
let's let's figure out so first thing is
heads goes to true or false
now i i want to just have a little look
forward to xml trees for one second here
yeah open the source ref page for
expression tree
like where am i going here
and then i want to get to
yeah okay let's see
okay
where do i go
so that's
a list of some of the things we plan on
extending this with
okay but now roughly what would an xml
tree look like
i think the payloads are
either the tag or something that
contains the tag and then oh yeah
okay here's the thing that's holding me
up right so
and by the way association is an
interesting one
um
i am unconvinced by this because i think
xml
is going to want to be imported
import xml as a tree
right rather than you are given an
expression and yes we have expressions
now involving xml elements but i don't
think we like those very much
i think we're going to want direct to
tree importing
i i think we will like xml element when
it's easier to work with them because of
the tree functionality
so i
i don't think we should you know okay
but okay fair enough
but
okay then we've got things like so this
is again a very orthogonal kind of issue
what we've got here like text element
yes there's a bunch of nested text
elements but all of these issues that
we're talking about here
probably show up again like for text
elements the leaves are just different
from the interior nodes blah blah blah
yeah
the point is that in these cases there
are heads that we will never want to
show like for example rule in
association
right and so there are some sort of
automatic decisions in these cases
okay
well i'm not saying there can't be a
second argument i'm just saying i think
we need options that could be
potentially bank switched by a second
argument
right yeah they're like
yes we need to decide priorities
right but i think these look i think
this stuff would always be the higher
okay so heads is one thing right
then we need the thing that what what
gets um
uh
you know what gets treated as atomic how
do we just
what is i thought it was excluded forms
am i am i misremembering no no there is
excluded forms yeah excluded forms is
what simplify has
i think excluded forms is the right
thing here
and then it's you know excluded forms
goes to blank pattern
or for example and that would mean don't
dig inside those
okay am i making sense
yep
okay the general case of these would be
something like a function that takes the
expression and returns what we consider
to be the new payload and the new
collection of children
right but that that's like a tree
operation i mean you might as well just
munch the tree at that point
it's no longer a display operation
you're actually changing the tree
i claim
whereas you don't want to change the
tree in a case like this i mean forms is
absolutely going to change the tree it
says don't build a tree for this
expression it just oh yeah yeah you're
right okay you're right you're right
you're right you're right i see so what
jose is suggesting is it's essentially a
tree map
i see what jose is suggesting is tree
map maps onto a bonafide card carrying
tree
but what jose is suggesting is given an
expression you want to do the analog of
tree map onto the expression
is that right
right so if we have a rule
in an association
uh rule of key goes to value
how do we express that
as a new level of tree
okay but i think what you're saying is
you want an expression map tree or
something
or a map tree
you want a way of generating of
algorithmically generating a tree from
an expression
which i claim is more than this function
should be signing up to do
so that's that function is nest tree we
have it and we were planning on having
expression tree in addition to all of
these have the option to do the same
thing that nest tree does
okay okay fine well it needs to know
even the ideas is more natural
like nest tree sounds like you're
nesting
like expression tree the idea was that's
the general purpose function for
converting an expression of any kind
into a tree
okay
okay well i don't completely understand
this yet but that's the thing okay so
then
then there's the um
then there's this stuff okay so that
this is
okay so
if we just had tree leaves style
tree non-leaves style
tree leaves label
is it styles or label it's vertex labels
right
yes it's vertex labels
i think it would have to be s because
we're saying leaves although like tree
element style and all of those options
were singular
no but this is okay tree leaves style
could be just a style for the tree
leaves prelude styles like a nicer way
of inputting tree element style for all
of the leaves
tree element style
would be
okay so the analog tree element style
will be for all elements
and tree leaf style tree element style
is for this particular element but you
can also specify
a list of rules for sub trees
okay i understand so this is a bank this
one has perhaps
would be extended to handle the leaves
case but
that's this right
that's where you give this so
we could potentially do
a little bit hacky because we'd have to
say
this thing leaves goes to whatever you
know what i think we should do if we did
that we should do an association because
that way it's not ambiguous
i think we should be
tree level of string leaves like just
support leaves in level specs
okay but then but so what will we do we
would say
tree element style
tree level
leaves
arrow whatever is that what you're
saying
okay all right so if that's the case
like if we just use the string leaves
that might be a problem no i think it's
important i think it's a problem yeah
um
but then what i would do is
we got to have a tree leave style that
is a shorter way to do the same thing
and the tree leaves style
this only takes it by position right
tree element style only takes it by
position
currently so this would be an extension
to also support this tree level
um ethan is commenting on a live stream
about wouldn't it be nice to have
labeling and styling like in the old
graph plot
the problem is the name of a tree
element is not obvious
unlike a graph where the name of the
node is the main story the names of
nodes here are a mess
only their positions are unique and the
positions are also a mess
um
and plot themes for trees are being
asked for here and i agree but okay so
let's
so by the way
presumably we also
what is the analog vertex size
i think we'll have a tree element size
really what are we gonna do when we have
dags
are we gonna have everything a dag of
everything
i mean
dag
bags are
graphs so maybe bag can reuse vertex
size
but the trees are not growing
fine because the labeling of their nodes
is different the only reason we really
need this different thing because
you
our
a particular node and then you specify
with positions all right okay so then
then what we've got here we've got the
separate issue of whether the whether
the things are shown as trees so that's
a question
of you know we've got the sub-expression
can i add a case five
yes whether the expression should be
held
because currently we have
another five structures held heads held
arguments etc
that wrap things in hold form
oh boy
okay so what this is either the
sub-expressioning or the holding
is really a function to be applied which
is more or less what jose was saying
it's a function to be try applied to the
sub-expression before it is placed on
the tree
right
yep where his heads are the head's uh
true or false is determining what the
children are
whether you include the arguments or all
sub-expressions yes i think so yeah
right but so what we've got is
tree element
function more or less
is a thing to apply
a function to apply
to every
element
well it's basically to determine the
payload to determine what will be put
what will be used as the payload
so that actually includes many things so
it's
it's the
so yeah we're not planning that for an
option that's just going to be a
that's
a proper argument like you specify
a structure by giving a pair of a
function to give the payload and a
function to give the children
and that's a totally general case
well you're saying tree expression tree
you're saying expression
and then you're saying this is
the you know
payload of node
and then you're saying this is children
of node yep and those are both functions
that just take an expression the first
one returns any expression the second
one returns a list yeah i understand but
but we what we need
is
the payload of node
why do we need this i mean that that's
that's the heads that that's a
generalization of the heads thing right
right
heads is
the way that
for expression trees
they're the two different variants of
what you think of as the children of
expressions
you know i don't get this i don't get it
i don't get it i think there's a display
there's all kinds of trees
you can represent them symbolically any
way you want but in order to work with
them you have to be able to do tree data
and you have to be able to do tree
children
yeah i get it i get it i get it i get it
i get it but i think
look what i'm saying is that every tree
thing should have some kind of tree
element dis
tree element display function or
something
okay which is the thing to be applied
to the content of that node to the
payload of that node to say how to
display the payload of that node and if
we had that we would solve tons of these
problems
yeah so i would say tree element label
function but yeah
okay
okay fine so tree element label function
and then
well i think we want then tree element
style function and so on now if that
label function gets two arguments
argument one
is um
uh is the is the is the content
an argument two
is the uh uh
some kind of location
then it might at least have a fighting
chance
if it wanted to of doing something that
varied with height in the tree
now what that doesn't give us is the
leaf non-leaf distinction
and i would argue that what we should do
for that
is to say that tree element label
function could say
leaves arrow funk
non leaves arrow funk
so that you could just say
you know non leaves arrow none leaves
arrow whatever you want it to do
shouldn't the syntax just be the same as
what we said above for tree element
style
no that's a really ugly syntax that's
going to be a really incomprehensible
syntax
it's going to be hard to document people
are not going to understand it what is
tree level arrow non leaves it isn't a
tree level is it
so yeah yeah non-leaves would be zero to
negative two
so can we pass the the height as third
argument
so we payload comma position comma
height
we could pass all kinds of stuff as the
third argument we'd have to think about
what would be most useful
yeah but that will be a way to at least
get this and then okay listen we've got
to go to the other parts of this meeting
so let's bring this back okay we've made
a lot of progress here but let's bring
this back and i think with this kind of
tree element label function
yeah we're going to need a style
function
i guess we're going to need a style
function as well
right i think it's going to be confusing
if the function versions work
differently than the non-function
versions
well then maybe we change them both yep
i'm i don't think that the um
look look listen listen we get the best
of both worlds if what we do
is to have these things be have the
possibility being an association
and not have the naked you know all goes
to whatever whatever whatever i mean
well i guess we could have a list yeah
if we have a list here or an association
where the elements are this type of
thing leaves goes to this we could have
the specific tree element you know one
two
you know one three one two goes to
whatever
see what i'm saying
now the only difference is these are
functions
well but it's okay i mean one case is
it's the naked thing in the other case
it's a function
this requires a bit of thought yeah
we're making progress but we haven't
solved it i like all the cases that
we've broken down and we'll organize
this and okay and i think you should
think ahead a little bit to what you
think is going to happen with things
like xml and text element and so on just
to see whether we can bring that into
the same framework
yeah
okay all right let's go back here
finally to what we actually were
supposed to be discussing
tree outline
so tree outline is a function
is that correct
perhaps you should start by calling that
tree something and do the outline so
that you see how it works right now
so it's a bunch of nested opens
right so now this relates also to
expression browsing i mean this is a
bigger topic right because what we
expect is that we're going to have
expression browsing expression illusion
this is a long-running project i mean we
talked about this for at least 15 years
okay let me give the example so i've got
a long list and right now if i say range
of uh you know
range of 10 000 or something oh for
goodness sake
range of a hundred thousand
well okay no range of range of ten
thousand
short
right i'll see something like this
and you know what we've long imagined is
that you could click this and see more
am i making sense
right
and
you know the other thing we've long
talked about i mean this particular
thing here
is a bit like a notebook except it's not
a notebook
and this type of structure i mean like
for example in find equational proof
we have notebooks that you can produce
there that essentially represent
structures that are like tree structures
or expression structures for that matter
am i making sense yeah anything that is
a trick could be placed here
well so you're saying tree outline could
operate on ordinary expressions as well
as trees
or it could be tree outlines for example
like i gave an example in my uh tech
conference talk of converting a notebook
into a tree and then displaying an
outline of it
like you can okay so
anything into a tree and then make an l
how do you convert a notebook to a tree
you
write a function to
give you what you consider to be the
data and you write a function would be
what you consider to be the children
buzz
we could add an old book structure to
expression tree
right that's what
it should be a second argument of
expression three
but that was what i thought jose's point
was was
you can convert
anything that is a tree into an outline
exactly yeah but it's got to be into
it's got to be converted to a tree first
which is probably okay because there are
many options i mean it reminds me in
order to produce an outline you'll have
to somehow specify what you consider to
be the tree structure
let me make a comment okay notebook
import i have found very useful have you
guys used notebook import
no no no nothing
so notebook import just you know it says
what features of a notebook to bring in
like all the subsections for example
see what i'm saying like if i do that
in here
and i say
you know
okay now i say notebook import
of
um and then i say something like um
uh
isn't that useful
yep
and if i say
i mean i i don't use it as often but it
has a way of making subsections as well
i mean sub pieces to this
and so in a sense that
type of thing
you know import okay to me to my mind
there are lots of things like json like
whatever else where there's essentially
import to a tree
you know it's an external thing and
you're saying import it to a tree
including perhaps notebook import i
don't know
but um
uh
okay so one so the case you're
describing here is it is represented as
a tree now i want to be uh you know
jumping branch to branch on it so to
speak
exploring it
which you're distinguishing from this
project which is
the um uh expression browsing project
which by the way should be on the global
project list if it does not it should be
there
so could somebody make sure it is avery
maybe you could do that
yes i can do that
yeah um
and uh
but okay but you believe this is a
different project from this project is
that right we should
for trees yeah
okay fine
all right so now
the question we're asking is given that
it's a tree
how do we show it as
uh like this okay
all right i'm finally in sync with
what's going on
okay so is this the graphic design
proposal
uh yeah and ux yeah
okay
and so the ux here
for some reason why does this remind me
so much i mean isn't this like a you
know it
okay question
is there a way of pulling my file system
into a tree
it's documented on nest tree and tree
how to do it yep
using file names and
is it a mess
nope
so if i look on tree
and where do i go
okay but that's not well whatever
right there
well
okay
fine but that's not really end user
friendly
i think we need some kind of tree import
or something
actually what what it really is
okay we say things like import string
which imports from a string
it's a little bit of the wrong way
around but i mean we could call it
if we called it
i see import byte array imports a byte
array
but what we want is something that is
essentially import tree
either that or elements for these
importing things but import tree
i mean or we actually want to call it
file tree
you know what i'm saying and and have
this be something you can just get
right same options as file name scan
file system scan actually what it should
be called this file system tree
that's the right name for it and we
should have that be
a um i'm gonna put that up at the top
here file system that will be a nice
function
because we've got file system map and
file system tree
could be the same thing as file system
map
but
you know with the default that it's just
the names of the files
probably very much the same kind of
thing except a lighting except that the
there'd be a
it would probably alight its arguments
in a different way
you know i'm saying so it would say root
to be clear this would be a thing that
returns a tree not a symbolic
representation of a file system
[Music]
it would be some what would he mean it
would be yes it would return free it
wouldn't have head file system tree that
is correct it would return a tree and it
would be
the tree of files
i mean that seems pretty useful to me
but now given that idea
every kind of file browser
is fair game you know what i'm saying
i mean like like uh you know if i have a
a random um
you know if if i'm you know like this is
a file browser right this this thing
here is a type of browser with these
kind of you know folder rings right or
or
you know or i have this those openers i
don't use mac
yeah those are openers
but then this
is another form here
you see which goes across like that
like our original documentation
yes that's right
lots of things are trees
what is that i've never used that
wow i've never used that i don't even
know what it is
some kind of carousel thing
huh
okay would it make sense to have
something like tree form i mean that's a
right just a symbolic form but doesn't
actually
modify the structure of the data we do
yeah okay
we have that for the old function before
would it look like this could it look
like noah's i mean to to have functional
xml or something well right i i agree i
think that treeform i agree with you
that as a display form that would be
very useful
right now i mean we do have that as a
display form right now but it is
you know it's an impoverished creature
it's very old
and it really needs to be updated right
that needs to be updated to be modern i
suspect we're going to update it once we
are completely satisfied with tree
okay
okay fine it's going to match tree
but then then that's the answer to
jeremy's point that basically i agree
with jeremy that it would be very nice
to be able to say slash tree form
for something although as we've seen
from the earlier discussion how you turn
something into a tree is not always
self-evident
um
okay but so the issue here is the thing
i'm pushing back on is what about all
the other browser modalities
here
you know you're describing a particular
one this looks very much like windows
here
making sense
that's true
so like what's an example of my feeling
would be these other modalities should
probably be different names
like this is an outline i don't know
that that side-by-side thing is really
an outline well i look
maybe it isn't but you know a notebook
has outlining
and it doesn't look like this
right
a notebook looks more like this if
anything
i mean the fact that this has the same
backbone as the tree is interesting
right it's got the same branches they're
just configured differently if i'm if
i'm not mistaken
right like there is a copy of the tree
in here correct
you mean this and essentially what what
go ahead sorry i was going to say that
this is actually a layout of the tree
it is right it's not an outline of the
tree
this is the tree
where that node name
is instead of being drawn in the node
it is drawn here
i mean what other things do we have like
a dendrogram or something has multiple
ways which by the way i hope
interoperates with trees does it
no
so it should
yep i should cluster tree and so on
um
okay but in any case
this thing here
is merely
well i think all of the browser forms
would be in a sense merely
let's see
i see it's an outline because things can
be closed up and and not displayed
that's why it isn't purely a
rearrangement of the tree
i mean there's clearly useful thing to
have i'm just wondering whether it's the
only i mean a technical thing is
currently it's returning
something with head opener view
maybe this should still be something
with head tree
but i think that's independent of like
what the ux yeah yeah right but i mean
so the possibility would be that this is
in fact
there's other aspects of it that we
should get to what's that
like there's issues with illusion and
things like okay but hold on so one
possibility is that this is an option to
tree that determines its display
but i just want to make a practical
point we should probably break off a
trees meeting independent of the ild
meeting because this is clearly taking
over the ild meeting it's like
like
like one of those some invasive species
of trees or something
the
um
that's cool that's an interesting idea
i like that idea that's a cool idea
is it implementable easily
who knows but i think that's a very cool
idea
so
as you go further through there are sort
of comparisons with data sets and how
that's formatted and this is sort of the
beginning of fact um
in the sense that you can
you can sort of you can focus in on a
part
in the same way that you can focus in on
a part of the data stats
i see
i i'm still not and with data set
i found okay so data that's a good it's
a good unification but data set
formatting
i mean uh
did the example
is that in the agenda somewhere of
showing a data set as a
yeah
tree
down i think it's literally the next bit
i might open something let's keep
scrolling illusion later
so there is the data sets for the um
yeah there is a there is an outline of
that
the point is dataset uses rectangularity
to make a more compact
display
whereas the tree is considered to be
more sparse a tree in other words the
difference between a general expression
and an array
is an array is a rectangularized
general expression where all the
you know whatever and so data set is you
assuming a certain degree of regula
rectangularity in its formatting
makes sense to me
i mean it's i just want to point out
though that
in a side-by-side browser view you would
get more
you know this will be more useful there
i mean that will be a nice version of a
data set as well the side-by-side
browser view in effect
i i am not a huge fan i must admit
to the in the you know this thing here i
mean i understand the breadcrumbs but
i'm not a huge fan
i don't know how we make it better
how do other people feel about this
i like the breadcrumbs yeah
okay well good i mean i find them usable
i just find a little bit confusing when
i'm down
i have to say
if i saw something that was more like a
data set analog
i mean when i use the the file system
browser and it has those multiple
parallel panels i find that quite useful
do you know what i'm talking about
agreed
even that in conjunction with
breadcrumbs
actually you know what you know what i
really i miss here
if i hit 27 total there yeah this is
what's wrong this is what's wrong
this should go
this should open this up like like the
first form of the file browser opens
that up in line
so i'm saying so in other words instead
of seeing two things here i see 27
things here yeah can you right click
like uranus and
hide it
hydro
right so data set does this
entry we're really interested in really
hiding it all like collapse it i know
that but i'm making a different point
i'm saying when i hit 27 total what i
want to see is in place
that opens
see what i'm saying that in place this
makes a great big thing down here
rather than that it goes to the
breadcrumb
well both both are useful you basically
need some way of easily accessing both i
think um
i mean you you could
you
the breadcrumb trail could could be
improved such that there is some kind of
slot machine thing up there um
i'm not really sure but well i think
that this could be
improved to have two different options
one is open go to drill down to this
this sub piece
and the other is open in place
and i leave it to ux and design to come
up with icons that make it obvious which
is going to happen
that's what's confusing to me i i knew
there was something that had confused me
it's that i would expect it to open in
place because that says something total
and what i would expect to see that's
what's confusing to me when i see a
greater than sign what i expected to do
i guess if i saw a double guillemet i
might expect it to go somewhere else but
with a single
greater than sign i kind of expect it to
open in place
jeremy do you have any comments on that
uh i was on viewed i think a plus sign
if you're going to open place is what
i'd expect
fair enough that's like a slide view on
ios where you would
so it's not the worst icon for what it's
doing now i i don't think it's the best
default action though i think i'd prefer
to do it in line two
by default
yeah
i think the problem is that it might get
very large and you would need scrolling
and i'm not sure you can put a scroller
there in the middle
we should look at that okay
i mean
okay just to show all of them either
though you could show yeah you could
just go to the more more of them yeah go
to more
and maybe that's a way that one could do
this
while
you know more here or something like
that somehow
oh this is your kind of thing
yeah i'm i'm thinking away i'm i i'm not
entirely sure what it should do but yeah
right okay but let's come back to this
so
you know is the question here opening
expanding and lighted branches
oh boy okay so this is something where
the root is not what you see you are you
are in a sub-branch
you are living in a sub-branch here
actually you know i want to comment on
something here again
if i go down and i drill into this
there's something about this maybe i
want an outer border around it or
something that doesn't make it clear
that i'm underground
i understand that the breadcrumbs should
make it clear that i'm underground but i
feel like it needs more than that
for example
if this border had something on it that
indicated that this was a
you know a sub-piece of something else
that was floating inside something else
that would help me
well if there was a carrot um from the
top of that that pointed to the either i
suppose because the breadcrumb could be
longer
it doesn't work
but like a carrot well yeah like where
your mouth down
yeah no no like a speech bubble carrots
kind of
at the top
yeah
yeah pointing upwards too yeah
oh this thing here i see that this thing
here had a little notch on it
so what you're saying yeah something
like that yeah
um
that would be good but i it could have a
notch over on this side too
that indicates i mean that would have to
interfere that would interfere with that
thing but i think that will be more
useful it's like this is a puzzle piece
that goes into something else
well actually the good thing with the um
allied tree outline is that it kind of
has that like if you scroll down there's
um
uh
i know there's this thing here
yes but there's yeah there's a bit
coming out of it
um sort of questions to the left yeah
and also the i like that the minus turns
into a back arrow
which minus
on so one
you see the opener has become a back
button
yes that is nice
that's quite nice
this is clever
i wouldn't say children i would just say
one to six of 40 or something
i think by the time you're talking about
children it's um
you know you've gone
you've gone very
i don't know what
uh it's very technical by the time you
because people just think of you know
it's a tree
but it's a tree that means something
that i'm just browsing because i'm
browsing some xml thing and they don't
think of it so much in that way
options for treehouse oh gosh okay
well the there was one point that is
very relevant to data sets which if you
just scroll back down
okay so the the the actual image there
um there's a
uh a little grabber
on the bottom left
this image here yeah okay yeah there it
is that would be wonderful to change the
window size
yeah so it's essentially changing back
sight in the store
that's wonderful that's a great idea for
dataset we super useful
so the question would be would the would
illusion be controlled by the max items
option like it is currently in dataset
or yes kind of dynamically by the image
size that you drag it to
well i mean if you change the image size
it would effectively change the max
items just as many other things you can
change about the appearance of the data
set change well the size of the items
can also
change
it's not necessarily i understand that i
understand that oh you mean well but i i
guess the size of the item affects max
items
the size of the items does the size of
items affects what's displayed here but
it does not affect max items if there
was a giant item it would still count as
one item
i see but but this is then a switcher
for max items
your point is this is not accurately
reflected it's more naturally a control
for image size than for max id well fair
enough you're right
you're right
well i mean it would just mean that as
you dragged it it would sort of jump in
in
discrete chunks
i'm not sure that'll be i think that
would might be horrifying no it wouldn't
just jump because no think about it if
the if the items are of different sizes
at different places down the item list
you could get completely messed up like
csg region tree
well you could if you move this down
right you think you're expanding it to
and then that changes max items
changing max items as you then scroll
through the item list might suddenly
have a giant elephant there
and you you know you don't you you
and then it would take up the whole it
would it would have the elephant plus
all its friendly
uh you know birds or whatever
flying around it you see what i'm saying
and and yes the height would be wrong
because there's an elephant there
um
anyway that's a minor
but i suppose that's why we were asking
should it should it mirror data set in
the sense that it should be controlled
by max items or should we use image size
and it sounds like image size would be
more sensible
yeah i'm not even sure that data set i'm
not even sure it works correctly in data
set to use max items because it could
have the same issue with a tall element
tall row it does it does
ugg well then that's probably a bug
um
there's clearly more to look at here but
i am supposed to do a different live
stream so i think i really have to go
um
and uh
outline view
so tyros on our live stream is
commenting that in the registry editor
there is a dual panel for children and
leaf differentiation yes i've seen that
actually somebody looked at the registry
editor because i agree it has some of
the same any any property list editor is
going to have the same kinds of issues
makes me wonder whether we could alight
an association this way nicely
because it's kind of what you have
well
no that's basically lighting a data set
or an expression that is a nested
association collection
all right we have to wrap up now um
till we continue at another time so
should we bring this back another time
yes but why don't we get a custom trees
meeting because it's going to take that
this is going to completely dominate the
ild meeting okay this is this is another
solid hour of work
um
and i mean it's very useful and a lot of
very good things here but it's just
going to take time
all right
see you all soon